TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hello, and welcome
to the "Developer Show."
I'm your host, Timothy
Jordan, and this
is a quick view of what happened
in the last week, also known
as the TLDR.
First, in the world
Android, there's
a new fingerprint API
sample available to help you
authenticate to remote servers.
The Play Game Services
tools set has a new feature
that will help you balance
your virtual economy so
that you can earn more
with in-game purchases.
Get started with Android and
Android Studio, and zombies,
with a new video from some
of your favorite Android
experts shot at the spooky
YouTube space in LA.
And the Big Android BBQ
happened last week in Texas.
Learn more about improving
Android performance
and more with
videos from the BBQ
on the Android
developer's channel now.
On the show today
are Ian and Katherine
to talk about Android and more.
IAN LAKE: Yee-haw.
KATHERINE KUAN: Hi, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Brillo and
Weave are a platform for IoT,
and the invite program
is now taking requests
to join so that you can
access code, documentation,
and the developer console.
And three big
announcements in the area
of training-- one, an Android
developer immersive training
course is going to be
offered in January, 2016
as part of a partnership between
General Assembly and Google
Developers.
There are also now courses
for developing apps
for Android Wear, Google Cast,
Android TV, and Android Auto--
all your favorite
new form factors.
Check out the blog posts
linked below for info on each.
And the tech
entrepreneur Nanodegree
has launched on Udacity.
It helps you learn what it takes
to design, validate, prototype,
monetize, and market
apps and grow them
into a scalable business.
OK, in the area of the
web, you can dramatically
improve the performance
of your web pages
with the Accelerated
Mobile Pages project.
This and similar presentations
were given at the SFHTML5
Meetup last week and are
now available to watch
on their YouTube channel.
The Chrome Dev Summit
is coming up soon.
Check out the
schedule and speakers
now live on the event site.
And on the show today
to talk about the web
is Paul Backhouse.
PAUL BACKHOUSE: What up?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: With that,
this message from Texas.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Hey, everybody, we're here
at the Big Android BBQ.
I'm Timothy.
-I'm Colt.
-I'm Chet.
-And it's too bad
that you're not here,
but that doesn't mean
you have to miss out
on all the awesome content.
-That's right, because we have
the videos from the Big Android
BBQ online right now on the
Android Developers YouTube
channel just for you.
-And you, and you, and the
one in the back there, but not
the person next to him.
-Well, no, but they're
here at the show,
so it's not really for them.
-So it's also for them.
-But it's not for them.
-No, but they saw it.
-They're going to keep going.
-They saw it live.
-You can check out
the playlist any time.
-I love the Big Android BBQ.
It's an entire weekend
of nerding out.
It's just wonderful.
-Now listen here,
we got two things
on the agenda besides that--
keynote, performance, barbecue.
-And, again, ROS
stands for Run of Slot.
-Welcome to "Forget the
Storage Permission."
It's not often we go
to a tech conference
and get to go to a talk
where we're specifically
going to be forgetting things.
-Welcome to my talk.
We're going to go
over system sleep.
I know you're all
really excited.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: (TEXAS
ACCENT) And that was the BBQ.
I got this hat for
going to the BBQ.
IAN LAKE: Do you like it?
KATHERINE KUAN: What
else did you bring us?
IAN LAKE: Barbecue, I hope.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, so I'm not
going to keep up the accent,
but I am going to keep the hat
on in honor of the Big Android
BBQ.
Pretty great time
out there, a lot
of great videos on playlist.
IAN LAKE: Mm-hmm, so many.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right,
we're going to check this out.
So the Fingerprint API, I'm
really excited about this.
I've been trying to make other
people excited about this, too.
But I think it's hard to draw
the connection from passwords
totally suck to
biometric recognition
helps solve the problem to,
hey, this is a cool API.
But it is.
IAN LAKE: Really hard on mobile,
because you're trading off
that security for the actual
usefulness of the feature,
and fingerprint
actually goes a long way
of making it super easy
to actually be secure.
KATHERINE KUAN: But what
about the devices that don't
have the fingerprint sensor?
IAN LAKE: Well, that's
part about this samples
is it's built on
the key store API.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Aha!
IAN LAKE: Which
works on all devices,
even if they don't have
fingerprint sensors.
KATHERINE KUAN: Oh, OK.
IAN LAKE: You actually
a confirm credentials
sample which goes through that
whole flow of going back to--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So you might
as well get started with it.
And then as more devices
get those sensors,
it's just going to work.
IAN LAKE: Magical.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Magical, OK.
The other thing that
I wanted to talk
about in the world
of Android is getting
started with Android and
Android Studio and zombies.
Let's talk about this in a
moment, but first, the clip.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I'm going to step you through
the process of getting started
with Android, using Android
Studio, while also sharing
some pro tips based on the
experiences of a real Android
start-up.
[YELLING]
-Well, that was unexpected.
-What the hell was that?
What's going on?
-Zombies.
Obviously those were zombies.
I don't know, how but I bet the
bald guy's somehow to blame.
-Oh, sure, solve one problem
with the Android Nomicon,
and suddenly this is my fault?
-How are we going to
survive a zombie apocalypse?
We don't have any training.
It's not like we can
go to Google Play
and download an app.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And it kind
of looks like he got away.
IAN LAKE: Uh, you
could say that.
You could say that.
You'll have to watch
the full video.
It is one of those
videos you want
to watch the whole way through.
PAUL BACKHOUSE:
Oh, what a teaser.
IAN LAKE: At least, you've got
to see what happens, right?
That's the whole point.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: But it
is one of those videos,
and that's what's so, I
think, unique about it
is that as for a
Getting Started video,
I wanted to watch every
single minute of it.
IAN LAKE: Well, zombies are fun.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
IAN LAKE: Well, not
fun-fun, but, you
know, like it's
engaging, and when
we're talking about tools
and stuff like that,
you've got to start
at the basics, right?
So this gives us
a really good way
of kind of going
through semi-real life.
Maybe your start-up isn't
going against zombies,
but going up
against an equally--
PAUL BACKHOUSE:
Maybe it will, right?
I mean, you never know.
IAN LAKE: Yeah, it could
be anything, right?
It doesn't have to
be zombies, right?
But it's just as important to
get through these same steps.
KATHERINE KUAN: And
I think that's where
a lot of the beginners drop off
because they get stuck on how
to actually set everything up.
IAN LAKE: Yeah, and once you
actually get an app going,
then it's pretty easy to
make those little changes
and stuff to make it awesome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, and
I think for our audience,
if you've been wanting to get
started in Android development,
or if maybe one of
your "friends--"
that means you-- haven't
had the chance yet,
please check this one out.
I think it's a really great way
to get started with Android.
IAN LAKE: Fantastic.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And zombies.
IAN LAKE: And zombies.
All right, moving
over to the web.
Last week, the SFHTML5
Meetup happened,
and one of the big topics
discussed was the AMP Project.
Paul, tell us about
the AMP Project.
Why is it important?
PAUL BACKHOUSE: So you
know I love the web, right?
KATHERINE KUAN: Hmm-mm.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes.
PAUL BACKHOUSE:
Right now, if you
look at the mobile web,
especially the part that
is new sites and bigger
sites, you really never
get to the content
because it's just really,
really cluttered with ads
and beacons an analytics.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You get
to the content eventually.
PAUL BACKHOUSE: Well,
eventually, right?
IAN LAKE: Four-second load time.
PAUL BACKHOUSE: But so,
after three seconds,
it turns out that 40%
of all users drop off,
and after 10 seconds,
everyone drops off.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's huge.
PAUL BACKHOUSE: Which
is crazy, right?
So that seems to be huge
issue, at least I think so.
And a lot of other people
thought so as well, including
publishers, because in this
conflict of interest scenario,
they want a great
user experience,
but they also want
money, turns out.
So the AMP Project
is a way to fix that.
It's born by all those partners
and companies, and what it does
is it's a restricted HML
framework, sort of library,
that you put in
your page, and then
it controls what can be
loaded, what can't, and they
kind of flow.
And so it means that
you can't actually
make your page slow anymore.
IAN LAKE: So it's
fast by default.
PAUL BACKHOUSE: Exactly.
IAN LAKE: Oh, that's fantastic.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And we
should note, though,
that it's still pretty early.
So it's a good time to check it
out and start playing with it
and give feedback.
PAUL BACKHOUSE: Yeah, that's
the whole purpose really.
Like, Lounge is sometimes
slated maybe for next year,
but we want people to
check it out very early
and work with us.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Very cool, wow.
IAN LAKE: Perf matters,
especially for the mobile web,
right?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Hashtag #perfmatters.
And for the last clip
of our show today,
the Electronic Frontier
Foundation recently
had their 25th
anniversary party,
and we sent along our
senior Open Internet
Correspondent, Derek Slater.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I'm here with Cindy Cohn,
the Executive Director
of the Electronic
Frontier Foundation.
Cindy, can you tell us more
about what the Electronic
Frontier Foundation is?
-Well, the EFF is around to make
sure that when you go online,
your rights go with you.
So we do legal cases.
We do policy work.
We build technologies,
all designed
to make sure that
the internet stays
free, open, and a place
of privacy and security
for everybody.
-The things that we, as longtime
supporters of EFF care about,
are now basic
human rights issues
that everyone cares about.
-We're here with Will Wheaton.
Will, thanks for joining us.
-I'm happy to be here.
-Will, how did you get involved
with the Electronic Frontier
Foundation?
What brought you to them?
-I found out about Electronic
Frontier Foundation
right after Operation Sundevil.
I knew a fair number of people
that were involved in that just
from IRC and bulletin
board systems,
and I thought the EFF
was doing for our rights
online what ACLU is
doing for our rights
in our meatspace world.
And it was in 2002
that I finally
had an opportunity to really get
involved with the organization.
-EFF has a building full of look
like astounding ninja lawyers
and activists and technologists
and just killer nerds.
-What would you say
to developers today?
What can they do to help support
the fight for internet freedom
in coding and beyond?
-I think that apart from
supporting the EFF in general,
which is like a
really important thing
to do, not just
with your dollars,
but also with your
name and getting
involved in sort
of the phone-ins
and the mass
letter-writing campaigns.
I think developing
software that considers
the privacy needs
of everyday people,
of people who
aren't super nerds,
is a really important
dimension here.
-Well, the first thing
that developers ought to do
is make sure that
you're developing tools
for a world you want to live in.
Make sure they've
got security, make
sure you keep your users'
protections in mind,
make sure you would want
to be a user of the tools
that you build.
I think this is an
important time right now,
where developing security
from the very beginning
of technologies is
tremendously important, more
important than ever before.
-Great.
Thank you, Cindy.
-Thank you all, to EFF,
to Cindy and to Sherry.
[END PLAYBACK]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
just before we go,
I'd like to ask the panel
a question, as usual.
What is going to be
your next BBQ start-up?
IAN LAKE: I really want to
bring our zombie start-up
to meter, barbecue on delivery.
That's a great idea, right?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's an
excellent idea, but barbecue,
not brains.
IAN LAKE: It's a barbecue, yes.
KATHERINE KUAN: Even
better than delivery,
I want to do a start-up
that 3D prints burgers,
so you can just have a snack
in the middle of the night.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Burgers in
the middle of the night,
it's what all of us
need, all the time.
PAUL BACKHOUSE: That's
nice, but what I really need
is an infinite strip of
bacon, like bacon tape.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
winner-- winner right there.
Thank your for joining us on
the "Developer Show" this week.
I'm Timothy Jordan.
I'm your host, and I
will see you next time.
Until then, this is Dev Life.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[TYPING]
-Come on, why isn't
this compiling?
What's going on?
Erg, come on.
-Wayne, what's going on, man?
-Hey, [INAUDIBLE].
I don't know.
It's just, I've been staring
at this code all day.
It doesn't compile.
I don't know what's going on.
-You, uh, are you missing
a comma just there?
-Oh.
[MUSIC PLAYING]